après dix ans d'absence diam's fait son
bras à laguiole alors festival de cannes
flics ce qui va être présent sur bon
j'adore cette j'adore cette femme
j'avais lu son livre qui est incroyable
on vous a fait un petit récap on en
parle juste après
la jeune demoiselle a aujourd'hui bien
grandi voilà plus de dix ans que l'on
n'avait pas vu la rappeuse diam's sur le
devant de la scène
ce week-end à l'annoncé son grand retour
pas pour la musique pour le moment mais
pour présenter son documentaire
événement salam au festival de cannes et
des images d'archivés mais ça raconte
son voyage depuis qu'elle a disparu de
l'oeil public un documentaire qui sera
diffusé sur la plate forme brute x qui
retrace la gloire la psychiatrie la
quête de sens et la conversion à l'islam
de diam's j'ai toujours était croyante
mais j'avais beaucoup de mal à me
raccrocher indues pour la première fois
l'ex rappeuse a décidé de se confier à
coeur ouvert en révélant ses vérités au
grand public ce retour sous le feu des
projecteurs pourrait peut-être décider
diam's a relancé sa carrière
c'est pas la vérité on revanche c'est
serré je crois que c'est un documentaire
absolument fou je n'ai pas encore vu
mais je ne vis plus que dans cette
attente faut voir les gens sur les
réseaux sur internet en larmes en disant
que c'est la plus belle nouvelle de
toute l'année quoique rares mais les
fans de diam's a fait dix ans qu'on
attend parce qu'elle à l'envoi des
poèmes de temps en temps un peu sur les
réseaux mais salam c'est sa plume ccl l
avais pas envie en fait d'être qu'on
raconte ses souffrances à des pressions
tout ce qu'elle a vécu durant ces dix
dernières années s'inquiète également l
avais pas envie que ce soit d'autres
personnes qui la raconte que ce soit
elle a repris mais ça sera un peu un
documentaire comme celui de johnny qui
est sorti sur netflix avec énormément
d'image d'elle elle même qui se raconte
quelques intervenants mais qu'on ne
verra même pas à l'image avec juste du
son comme le documentaire de johnny
c'est un événement parce que ça fait dix
ans qu'elle n'a pas parlé dans les
médias français sa dernière interview
c'était à 7 à 8 en 2012 et ça va être un
film dans lequel elle revient sur toute
sa carrière et ça envoie comme le
signale qu'il est apaisée aujourd'hui
qu'elle est à l'aise avec ce qu'elle est
et ce qu'elle est devenue donc c'est un
film qu'on a vraiment hâte de voir et
qui va être diffusé à cannes alors on en
extrait avec deux avec fabula qui
revient sur les moments difficiles de sa
carrière notamment et notamment sa
dépression regard des gens savent mais
la numéro un du rap français traverse
une lourde période de dépression
le matin même à sortait de l'hôpital
c'est la période complexe de sa vie où
elle était entre guillemets bourré de
cachetons c'est à dire que voilà et
travers c'est vraiment une période
difficile au retour de concert pour
ramener vivre des moments de scène
absolument incroyable où aller fait
toute la tournée des zéniths août et à
chaque fois c'est un entre cinq et dix
mille personnes chaque soir quant à
rentrer chez elle à l'époque elle avait
petit appart dans le 14e arrondissement
de paris tu la compagnie un peu on était
de 3 et puis juste avant de partir
l'année et bonmalais j'aime me retrouver
tout seul tu vois il y avait aussi ce
côté ou d'un seul coup tu passais de dix
mille personnes à le lendemain plus rien
quoi tout seul dans ton appart salue la
production dont
guillaume est ce que tu pourrais le dire
est ce que ça laisse sous-entendre qu'il
y aurait une possibilité de retour non
non non non répond je lui dis à deux
minutes et tout s'est bien passé
c'est dommage parce que franchement non
mais tous ses proches le disent dans le
documentaire après les dons qu'elle
réalisait le corps est lisse même ce
documentaire elle a écrit plusieurs
livres elle est aussi actif sur les
réseaux sociaux diam's et la recontre
notamment sur instagram elle s'exprime
donc voila mais la musique c'est pas de
la démarche du coup de faire ces
documents parce que tout le monde a eu
envie de le faire nous honnêtement vous
voulez la voir tout le monde rêvait
d'avoir diam's et je pense qu elle c'est
elle qui est le plus à même de raconter
son histoire surtout qu'il ya beaucoup
de bêtises qui ont été dites sur elle
c'est très important pour elle de
raconter ses justifications pardon sur
sa personne j'essaye juste de comprendre
le but cinéma pour revenir
parce que la voilà elle a pris des
figues parce que je pense qu'elle a eu
un confort de travail très important et
qu'elle a plutôt comment ce qu'elle
pense et c'est brut c'est brut
les bruitages
avant avant d'avancer on a un extrait
dur de votre dock son ex qui parle elle
expliqué à une époque elle l'a très bien
expliqué même à l'abri pris un peu le
melon à tel point qu'elle veut qu'on
appelle gamme quant à mélanie roy
j'étais son temps final sujet par
exemple m dunn qui me dit tu sais même
moment ne m'appelle plus mélanie
amap alliance est ce que tu as lu par
promène oui
je suis je me suis dit c'est trop payé 2
je me dis c'est trop
c'est trop quoi ils disent c'est une
souffrance alex comme ses souffrances
dans cette souffrance
je suis le pourquoi du coup
voilà un extrait donc ouais pour
rectifier l ai pas pris la grosse tête
elle était juste dépassé par le succès
et la renommée marre que les gens la
considère plus comme dire puisque
mélanie mais jamais pris la grosse tête
mais ce qu'elle raconte ce qui est
raconté dans ce documentaire qui est
très émouvant réalisé par deux grandes
nana d'ailleurs qui ont fait des films
magnifiques comme divine 1 comme
s'appellent houda benyamina qui avait
fait ce très beau film raconte un peu
toutes ces dérives et en fait tous les
séjours en hôpital psychiatrique
également ses tentatives de suicide
également sa conversion à l'islam
c'était en 2008 je crois que c'était
extrêmement sincère mais ce que je peux
vous révéler c'est qu'elle n'ira pas au
festival de cannes présenter le film
dommage
c'est dommage mais c'est logique c'est
une faute et
cohérent dans ce qu'elle vaut pas ce
matin se consacre à sa famille et à sa
foi voilà donc elle était heureuse comme
ça elle a pas besoin d'aller se monter
les marches de cannes qui quand même un
gros spectacle paillettes et strass et
paillettes voilà exactement confettis
donc n ira pas